wie würde sich dein leben verändern wenn
du innerhalb einer minute einschlafen
könntest ich habe schon häufiger von
methoden gehört mit denen man angeblich
sofort einschlafen kann und jetzt habe
ich mir gedacht wir tun wer ist und so
was wirklich abziehen zu können
ich werde also alles in meiner macht
stehende tun um am ende dieses videos
innerhalb von einer minute an schlafen
zu können und zwar zu jeder beliebigen
zeit an jedem beliebigen ort und in
jeder beliebigen position
dafür werde ich verschiedene techniken
ausprobieren die quer über das ganze
internet verteilt sind und ausprobieren
ob das leben funktioniert oder ob dort
wieder alles möglich war
und das allerwichtigste ist werde ich
dieses experiment nicht beenden bevor
ich mich innerhalb von einer minute
einschlafen kann für meine recherche
nach der schnellsten und effektivsten
methode einzuschlafen wenn ich über
einige informative und sehr
aufschlussreiche informationen gestoßen
und auch darauf ein guter schlag ist für
einen optimalen schlaf unabdinglich
aber eines der größten hindernisse für
die schnelle einschlafen
das ist uns unbekannt wie spreche ich
sie an was wenn man herausfinden dass
ich mist gebaut
warum ist eigentlich so eine banane kann
das leben eigentlich sind wenn ich mag
mich das süße junge aus der schule auch
ich lese nur vor jeder kennt das und
sagt wenn ich nicht häufig existenzielle
oder extrem wichtige fragen und gedanken
in meinem kopf herumschwirren habe bevor
ich einschlafe sind meine gedanken
dennoch oft viel zu laut man kann ja
schlecht an nichts denken oder in
unserem alltag sind wir ständig damit
beschäftigt uns mit dingen zu
beschäftigen die es eben nicht zulassen
dass wir uns mit den unangenehm aber
manchmal wichtigen fragen des lebens
beschäftigen bis wir am abend im bett
liegen und keine andere stimulation und
sie mehr ablenken kann
wir gucken youtube-videos wir schauen
einen film wir spielen spiele wir machen
sport wir lesen wenn wir autofahren
hören die musik um die offenen krieg ich
stehe der unseres verstandes zu
übertönen
wenn wir ein computerspiel spielen dann
werden unsere sorgen verdrängt aber wenn
dann so ein ladebildschirm einfach die
stimulation wegnimmt
ihr wisst genau was ich malen für mein
experiment werde ich also eine stunde
vor dem schlafengehen alle sozialen
medien verband um an den klaren kopf zu
bekommen
des weiteren wird ein gesunder und vor
allem regelmäßiger schlafrhythmus
komplett unterschätzt regelmäßig im
sinne von jeden tag zur selben zeit ins
bett gehen jeden tag zur selben uhrzeit
aufstehen egal wie unangenehm es morgen
ist und egal wie verlocken das ist
einfach diesen snus button zu drücken
mein eigentlicher schlafrhythmus ist
eigentlich von 22 30 bis 36 morgen
und das ziehe ich eigentlich auch
relativ gut durch das aber nicht immer
zu 100 prozent funktioniert werde ich
das für dieses experiment auf 23 bis 7
uhr morgens verschieben um der anderen
bisher mehr professoren haben zweitens
bleibt beim essen sowohl youtube als
auch musik aus meinen gedanken freien
lauf zu lassen und als dritten schritt
täglich 20 minuten meditieren
beim meditieren versuche ich an nichts
zu denken und jedes mal wenn sich ein
gedanke breit macht und das passiert
gerade am anfang sehr häufig lediglich
meine aufmerksamkeit zurück auf meinen
eltern oft trifft der mann in gedanken
ab und vergisst die meditation um dann
erst nach zwei minuten seine
aufmerksamkeit zurück auf den alten zu
lenken
dadurch trainiere ich mein gehirn darauf
mich nicht unfreiwillig von meist
zumindest aktuell belanglosen
gedankengängen verführen zu lassen und
hoffe diese fähigkeit mit ins bett zu
nehmen
mit diesen maßnahmen sollten meine
gedanken genug gehören die zahlen so
dass ich mich beim einschlafen nicht
mehr stören wie in allen bereichen des
lebens spielt ernährung auch beim schlaf
eine sehr wichtige rolle weswegen ich
industriellen zucker weißmehl und andere
einfache kohlenhydrate komplett meiden
werde und vor dem schlafengehen werde
ich ganz auf werbung verzichten damit
mich meine verdauung nicht beim
einschlafen stört industrieller zucker
ist etwas was ich auch schon vor diesem
experiment so gut wie gar nicht gegessen
hat ausser wenn dies gegessen habt wenn
ich nämlich zufälligerweise die
lieblingsschokolade von meiner freundin
sehen ist die auch schon weg und das
werde ich eben in den nächsten tagen
oder eben wie lange auch immer ich dafür
brauchen wir bis sich die einen minuten
marke knackte komplett weglassen
zumindest wenn ihr so viel süßigkeiten
ein bisschen besser versteckt in diesem
sinne guten appetit bevor wir es so
geheim navy seals technik vom anfang des
videos kommt fehlt uns noch der sport
sport fördert einen gesunden schlaf aber
nicht nur die qualität wird dadurch
verbessert sondern auch die einschlaf
geschwindigkeit beziehungsweise die
schlaf latenz deswegen werde ich über
die dauer des experiments 30 minuten
laufen gehen all das gibt uns die
perfekten voraussetzungen für den 1
minuten schlaf und hätte auch darüber
hinaus noch sehr sehr viele vorteile für
unser leben aber um wirklich sofort
einschlafen zu können brauchen wir noch
etwas besonderes
eine top secret navy seal methode aus
einem video von sonnenseite in dieser
technik geht es darum schritt für
schritt jedes einzelne körperteile zu
entspannen was man langsam schläft diese
technik und die sogenannte 874
atemtechnik werden wir dabei helfen das
unglaubliche ziel zu erreichen innerhalb
von einer minute einschlafen zu können
tag 1 1 schlaf versuch 1 es ist gerade
15 30 und ich trainiere das einschlafen
ich stelle mir meinen teil auf 20
minuten benutzte dabei bislang nicht
gestört zu werden und lege mich hin die
874 atemtechnik geht wie folgt man atmen
vier sekunden gleichmäßig einhält sieben
sekunden den arzt und art mit acht
sekunden gleichmäßig aus es ist gar
nicht so leicht das gleichmäßig
durchzuziehen ohne nach der langen pause
sofort hektisch nach luft zu schnappen
vielleicht bin ich für mich ist es eine
herausforderung die technik sowie folgen
ohne dass es unangenehm wird zu beginn
wäre mein größter aber nur schneller und
das ist nicht besonders förderlich um
einzuschlafen
naja eine gute übung war es allemal tag
2 1 schlaf versucht 3 es ist 16 uhr und
genau wie gestern nachmittag und gestern
nach zähle ich wieder von 1 bis 8 und
halte mein atem an
um das muster weiter zu verinnerlichen
danach probiere ich zusätzlich die
entspannungstechnik aus dem navy seal
video hierbei entspannt man zunächst
alle gesichtsmuskel zunge kiefer wangen
dann schultern dann arme beine füße bis
man schließlich seinen kopf entspannt
und versucht an nichts zu denken
diese technik fehlt mir allerdings
deutlich leidet da ist die andere tag 3
1 startversuche sechs gestern abend
hatte ich trotz aller bemühungen
probleme einzuschlafen vielleicht weil
ich durch meine eigenschaft übungen
tagsüber zwei nickerchen gehalten hat
zuerst ist wieder die 874 atemtechnik an
der reihe und ich merke wie ich damit
immer mehr in einen gedankenlosen
zustand abdriftet er ähnlich wie bei
einer meditation ist nach unfassbaren
geschätzten zwei bis drei minuten schlaf
ich schon ein es ist wirklich ein
unbeschreibliches gefühl da ich durch
diese technik bei vollem bewusstsein
mitverfolgen kann wie ich langsam die
kontrolle über meinen körper verliert
bis ich letztendlich schlaf tag via
anschlagsversuch acht ich kombiniere
diesmal beide techniken und entspannend
zuerst mein gesicht und dann den rest
meines körpers
ich habe festgestellt dass es besonders
wichtig ist die zunge zu entspannen und
den unterkiefer in eine position zu
bringen in der sich meine zähne im
entspannten zustand nicht berühren dann
hat mich wieder vier sekunden einhalte
sieben sekunden den atem und 8 sekunden
aus ungefähr dreimal bis maine physische
körper wieder bei vollem bewusstsein
meiner wahrnehmung entgleitet und
einschlafen nur ca einer minute ich habe
tatsächlich geschafft auch nur vier
tagen haben wir verschiedene maßnahmen
erlaubt beinahe sofort einzuschlafen und
so wenn ich diese fähigkeit beibehalten
kann wöchentlich ungefähr zwei stunden
zeit zu sparen einfach weil ich nicht
mehr jeden tag 20 minuten braucht um
einzuschlafen was mir persönlich am
meisten geholfen hat war die meditation
und damit die fähigkeit einen klaren
kopf oder sogar lernen kopf zu bekommen
und das entspannt von zunge und kiefer
und die atemtechnik wenn ihr aber auch
sowas vor hat dann kann ich nur
empfehlen auch alle maßnahmen zu
ergreifen um ein bestmögliches ergebnis
reduzieren und das war es von diesem
komplett anderen video wie sonst ich
beschäftige mich privat ziemlich viel
mit solchen experimenten und
persönlichkeitsentwicklung deswegen
dachte ich ich nehme einfach mal mit
vielleicht hat er gefallen und jetzt
bleibt nur noch zu sagen wenn die
schneiden lernen möchte dann schaut man
die beschreibung da ist nämlich der link
zum trailer von meinem schnittkurs drin
hier hilft euch dabei mit zwölf stunden
video lehrmaterial premiere pro zu
beherrschen und hilft mir dabei jetzt
schon meinen traum leben zu können unter
anderem dank der 350 leute die mit
diesen kurs schon zuvor gelernt haben
und wenn er mich auf dieser reise
begleitet hat dann lassen wir gerne abo
da und dann sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder macht's gut
[Musik]